Film Courage: What's been your hardest year in
filmmaking and why? Rachel K. Ofori: You're gonna make me
cry no so
I don't know I'll start the story and if
this is like too much for TV like just let me know. Film Courage:  Okay.
Rachel: But I lost a pregnancy during
pre-production Oh
so of what definitely behind and it was
the hardest laws even though I've lost
people I didn't realize how bad that was
I didn't even hear about people they
have miscarriage and such in mind might
happen while I was I was I was put under
like I was not conscious for it wasn't
my decision it was it was one of those
things very traumatic but during
pre-production I was on set like you
know what I shouldn't have been right
after that but um yeah it was that was
so hard but I put it away
because I had a job to do we were about
to go into production time to get moving
and I did I went and moved and we had we
filmed the dream sequences in what deaf
Lisa Hynes separate from the film and
they're like their own little movie
because it's different it looks
different it's weird it's a dream we
decided in the Sun Center studios in in
essen Pennsylvania and it's a very eerie
and weird so we shocked him as her own
movie so we like what really hard into
it and this was like a ye like 2016 or
something and um we shot it and right
after that I had like a little break
from the crazy and I'm talking about
like I went down like it was like all
the pain or motion that I was
suppressing kind of just came out and I
wasn't used to that level of pain
because of that type of pain because I
don't suppress things people stuff comes
up I deal with it but that was different
it was like a whole nother heart strain
that was pulled so that was really tough
and then getting back into production
that's where some things had happened
with one person kind of destroying some
of the the synergy or whatever you want
to call it the the culture the the
caring nature of the set was kind of
disturbed by a person and I had to fire
them and during that time there was a
producer that was kind of helping us on
some business ends that kind of did some
shady things I had to get rid of them it
was like all these things they're really
hard to deal with for anyone but I was
in this really bad space like in not
only bad like
was depressed but it was like my heart
was like burst open like it was very
much an open wound and I knew it and I
communicated it to my inner circle in
the in the group like you know like the
director knew at that point they didn't
know when it happened they knew when I
had to go back to the hospital because I
had complications from the surgery
during production I was like in the
hospital on my computer and they're like
man put the computer down like it was
like crazy time and then in the same
time I got a fire someone that was
really important to the production and I
had to get rid of a relationship that
would have made distribution easy
because he was shady like stuff like
that happened during that time so I
think that year of pre-production was
not even though that was the moment that
wasn't that year wasn't the hardest it
was why why we were in that lul and then
coming back at the production and
finishing the project it was so hard
because it was really it's just the
hardest thing to do to finish a film a
feature for like film is the hardest
thing to do on in our industry right but
then to be dealing with some of the
hardest things I dealt with in life on
the side of my husband not losing a
child like that was really hard and then
like other things that pop up you know
these you know draining situations they
have nothing to do with the movie but it
has to do with the people making the
movie and then things like being aware
of and I say shady I mean like they were
doing some bad business and I had to
distance myself from that so all these
little things yeah that made it the
hardest year and I think we all grew
from it myself included like where we
would deal with we were dealing with a
lot I mean there were deaths in we had
to learn that our production died right
after someone that's in the movie so
it's hard for me watch the film because
he passed away and we had a member of
the crew their grandmother died we had
my ad had to drop out during production
during the same time because she had a
family death and different little things
like that they had nothing to do with
the film but those things that come up
is like are we going to lose because of
something that's not the loss like we're
going to make the film right like we're
going to keep going so we just had to it
was a moment
huge perseverance I'll say that and it
was big perseverance like big hurdles to
get over and it was like when those
things were like you know you get over
hurting it was never that was alright
another another another one while still
having a very personal like emotional
wound so that was that was hard and
overcoming that though lets me know on
this little film the things that we went
through and growing leaps and bounds and
getting through it and now having a
theatrical release and
you know all the things that you just
can hope for we we achieve that with all
this hopefully all that won't happen on
the next one right but also we know we
can handle it so when things happen
which they will when things pop up or
things happen to us we've already proven
we can overcome things that are really
difficult and not in like you know you
go through something it's hard and you
go to something else you're like whoa
that was nothing you know I know this
was something what we dealt with so if
we call overcome that we can keep going
if I can keep going if I can remain a
place of I can still encourage someone
that day when I just cried all night in
my two hours and I could have got some
sleep I can get through anything
anything so there's no project that I
can't confidently say to an investor I'm
going to make this film and I'm going to
get this outcome because if I said that
on this one and we got the outcome I
have to do that on anything and that's a
that's another level of confidence that
doesn't happen without adversity so if
you achieve something in a moment of
darkness how much easier is the light
how much easier is sunrise like just you
know we've got we've gotten through it
so we can do it again we do it again we
could do it again
so in those moments of weakness or in
those moments where things are going bad
I know that I'm not gonna crumble
because in the time where I should have
in the moments I had the more crumbly
moments I brought it back together we
kept going and that had a lot to do with
the people I was working with the team
that was created and why that team
worked and why they were able to like
latch on like lock arms with me and move
forward when we just lost somebody we
cared about you know like those things
is something that can't be diminished in
any sense of the word that's why certain
people from what densities behind that
are also in my company now like the
audacity and it's our company it's not
like my thing and I'm just putting you
in little pieces like it's ours because
we went to war together
so now we can go ahead and make these
videos and we can we do all these little
projects for people outside of just to
make major film we have two shows going
on right now there were one in
pre-production one in production and all
you see that we're doing I just feel so
confident and room with these people
because I saw them in bad moments and
that's a luxury because usually you hire
these people we have an idea of what
they'll do and try to be prudent but
then you give it to something you're
like oh they couldn't handle the
pressure
I know these people can they've been
pressurized and they've been pressure
tested and these these guys aren't going
anywhere so I think that that's
something that was very important for me
a lot of people we lost and I don't mean
on the desk side I mean like people that
just didn't didn't work they couldn't
handle the pressure
you know we finished a film with them I
know no you're not who I want to go to
war with so I scaled down the the inner
circle but that circle is so solid and I
know we can achieve anything going for
it and I know I can I can answer any
promise any thing put in front of me by
somebody with the money the investor or
a network or whatever because we can
overcome we can overcome anything what
about the best year that's here right
now
right now is the best year it's still
going and it's not just because so many
things are happening it's kind of like
you do something and you gotta keep
telling yourself it's gonna work it's
gonna work and then you get to that
moment where just it's working you don't
have to tell yourself anymore and that's
actually hard sometime too because it's
like you've developed this place for so
long where you're like oh come on it's
gonna work you're gonna be alright keep
going keep going and then it's working
and like even Chad my exactly producer
had to remind me like this is great I'm
like come on alright so that like you
know but it's like you get to kind of
enjoy it too I'm still very much in like
you know a fixer mould always but it's
it's one of those things where you can
actually say it it worked
something worked not it's going to work
it worked and then go on to the next
thing knowing you made something work so
this is this right now is the best year
so far yeah so coming off of what was
the worst year now going into what seems
like the best year
yeah for sure for sure and that that
contrast to be the same person in both
in
yeah we got at the edge : yes we're
going to be on the platforms that I
promised the our executive producer yes
he's gonna make his return and all those
things that you as a producer like I got
to do this but the win for me was
remaining Who I am in those adversities
and regardless of anything that happened
for me first because I look at myself
first to remain Who I am and then watch
the people that I believed in do the
same we won like there's nothing that
can tell me we lost because that
happened and even before we got our
distribution and before we like things
were finalized we just it was a sense of
we won because we finished when it was
really bleak at one moment you know so
it's like we we did it we did that so
any other achievement it's like wow this
is the icing of the cake but we've
already made the cake and guys it tastes
good and we can do it again and again
and again because we had the ingredients
and as long as we hold fast foods and
greens I think another thing that I'm
really mindful right now is we won we
built the cake or made the cake and all
those analogies but we can't forget why
it worked
we can't start to believe like I'm great
no no it worked because you did great
things so continue to do the great
things because I think that's where
hubris can creep in and we can start
thinking like man I'm good and yes we
should think that we should be like yes
we're good we like it but also like I
did good it's so much more powerful than
I am good it's so much more because
we're people we're not perfect so I am
good is a wavering thing because then
you do something bad you're like oh I'm
bad no you're not
you did good so even when you lose if
you did good sometimes you win sometimes
you learn learn from it and I'm the only
out from John Maxwell is a great book
definitely a one of those books that I
recommend but you don't have to lose you
can as long as you're doing good so if
you're keeping certain things is what
you're doing know that that's gonna work
eventually people had that perseverance
but you can't go into something and do
bad practices and when and then think
I'm good I'm bad that you've gone back
and forth between no forget I am just
stick to I do and I do this I do that I
do that I do that and that's what I can
say we did that we
did this and it one we did that in a
mega project we did that and we're able
to achieve the goals that we set forth
and that was what we can do with the
smallest amount of money the least
amount of resources the smallest team so
imagine what happens when we're given
the next level and which is what we're
doing right now so I'm excited about
this greatest year and I think the worst
year has a lot to do with it though
because it wouldn't even feels good if
we didn't if we didn't win in that way
you said what the worst year you still
remained who you are can you explain
what that means yeah I think I had I
mentioned this to my team a lot so to
say that I had the worst year and remain
who I was best year remain who I was I
tell my team they the close ones saw me
an ugly moment right I cried in front of
them and this is like Rachel she's not
emotional right I cried in front of them
and I mistook something from one of the
like I said the inner inner circle and I
had an ugly moment and every was like oh
she okay like it wasn't like how dare
she
I had an ugly moment of like not cursing
any by just crying I cried I had a very
weak moment it within this time of the
craziness and I told them though I cry
in things because I had to tell them
what I was feeling
and I told them and then we talked about
it was over so I remained myself in a
place of I could have got ugly in that
moment because it seemed like certain
things were happening or maybe I was
feeling insecure because of what I went
just went through or just I was all
right like I was experiencing things I
wasn't used to like feeling like less of
a woman because I didn't carry a child
to term or those things that you don't
you don't really know are happening
until you see something that's me that's
not me why am i acting like that you
know so that moment though in that
moment I still communicated what I was
feeling
to my team which is what I tell them I
need them to do always I was like I
don't care what's up yeah it's something
I preach but I did it I did that and for
that reason it didn't spiral into a big
problem it didn't grow it didn't disturb
our way of life that those ugly moments
don't destroy a team it's because you
let that ugly moment or you let that
ugly thought Fester
and things like that so I spoke to them
and we find we did it and we're dealing
we just dealt with something else in the
team somebody was dealing with something
and I brought that moment up in that in
that meeting you guys remember when I
had the ugly moment remember the ugly
moment that's what we call it and her
like Rachel wasn't that bad I'm like no
that for me is as bad as it's gonna get
me crying like all that so and I said
did anybody leave me in that moment no
you guys knew I was dealing with
something because I told you so all that
matters is we can remain the solid team
we can remain winners if we continue to
communicate and throw it up any doubt
and do those things that we all preach
to I preach to them to do but still
maintain a level of self so regardless
of that moment I had the next day it's
like alright I'm still gonna get up in
the morning I'm gonna work my butt off
for you guys the matter if I was crying
I'm working where you at I might say
like you know like I'm going to still do
all the practices that I do so I worked
really hard despite the pain I treated
people with respect to spite the pain I
communicated when I had a ugly moment
despite the view
I didn't clam up I didn't do the things
that I'm a Taurus like you know like we
were stubborn we kind of I fought that
and it wasn't stubborn in a moment I
communicated and and I treated people
with respect when they were treating me
bad someone was trying to swindle me I
still treated them with respect I let
them know what they did wrong and then I
treated them with respect
I didn't demoralize them and spread the
nonsense around and tell everybody what
they did so yeah remaining yourself is
so important and good and bad even more
so sometime and good because like I said
the hubris that pops up when your Wow
it's going good let me go ahead and do
XY and Z or feel like this like wait a
minute that's not you that's the
practice that's the outcome so the
outcome has nothing to do with the
winner like if you're a winner like the
Serena Williams or whatever like she
just lost the US Open again right but
she won she she went out there she went
through what she went through and she
still performed she still I mean second
place I mean goodness gracious for the
woman she's gone through but she went
out she played that's what she is she's
a hard worker she went out she trained
yes this body is not what it used to be
because of the pregnancy but I'm still
gonna train I'm still gonna work hard
I'm still I'm not gonna give myself
excuses or
passes to have bad practices or treat
someone bad and that's what I mean by
remain yourself in the good times and
the bad times and I was able to do that
thank goodness in a time when it was it
was clutch and sports what we say or
when it was sublime or when it was
paramount like it needed to happen where
I remained myself for it to work
so don't let everything crumble and who
you are those those those identifying
factors about yourself when things get
really bad that's the that's why you
were yourself that's why that's why you
built these things in for this moment so
don't let it fall apart or don't let the
ugliness of people bring ugliness in you
or react badly remain who you are
you